[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
RAY TSANG: Thanks
everyone for being here.
And for those of you
watching on the livestream,
thank you for
joining this session.
My name is Ray.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
HADI HARIRI: And I'm
Hadi, a Developer
Advocate at Jetbrains.
RAY TSANG: And today we're
going to talk a little bit
about writing mobile
applications, especially
the back-end.
And I know a lot
of you are probably
writing mobile apps
today and you're probably
aware with-- you know
how to use Kotlin
or you're learning
to use Kotlin.
And then what
about, once you have
the front-end, what about
the back-ends, right?
So today, that's what
we're going to talk about.
We're going to show a little bit
about the different frameworks
that you can use, specifically
Spring Boot and Ktor.
And we're going to see how
we can actually deploy this
onto Google Cloud
Platform by using App
Engine and a few other things.
HADI HARIRI: So for this we've
got this amazing, awesome
Android application that
neither Ray nor I wrote,
because we both completely
suck at Android development.
It was written by Seth.
Raise your hands.
So if anything goes wrong,
it's also his fault.
And basically, what it
is, it's just an uploader.
So you can upload
your images and then
you can list them
and do some sharing
and black and white filtering.
And that's what we're
going to show you
how to develop on the
back-end side of it.
RAY TSANG: Right.
And that's pretty much all we
have for today for the slides.
And we're going to
try to code everything
in the next 40 minutes or so.
How many people would think
that we can actually do this?
Wow, nobody.
Oh, a few people.
Wow, thank you.
All right, let's get started.
HADI HARIRI: Have faith.
RAY TSANG: Yes.
So we're going to get started.
So the first thing
that I'm going to do
is to write a back-end
using Spring Boot, OK?
And we're going to
implement probably
half of these functionalities.
And one of the easiest
ways to get started
is to actually go
to start.spring.io
and this will help you
bootstrap your service
or your application
in the back-end.
And how many people
here use Gradle?
Gradle?
Just about everyone.
Maven?
Just a few, that's nice.
Right.
So I actually use
Maven a lot, so I'm
going to use the Maven
project, but you can choose.
But I think we can all
agree on that we're
going to use Kotlin
for the language here.
If you scroll down
a little bit, you
can choose some of
the metadata here,
like the package name
and stuff like that.
But most importantly,
I need to make sure
that this has the
right packaging format.
For our demo today, we're
going to deploy a WAR
file for the web application.
But in the future, we can also
deploy a JAR file as well.
If I scroll down even
a little bit more,
this is the important part
where we can pick and choose
the capabilities I want
to add to my application.
So for example, I already
added the web dependency,
because I need to be able to
respond to a HTTP request.
I'm going to use some of
the Google Cloud Services.
And so I'm going
to add GCP support.
And I'm going to cut down on
some of the boilerplate code
that otherwise you may have
to write for your back-end,
so I added this rest
repository, which
I'm going to show in a minute.
And from here, you can
generate a new project.
It will be a zip file.
You can just download it.
And you can unpack it.
And you can open
this up in your IDE.
So this is a fresh new
project, which I just created.
And I'm going to open this up.
And there we go.
I'm going to just
make sure that I
can synchronize this
directory a little bit so I
can get the latest file.
And if I scroll down
here, I can actually
open up the Kotlin application.
And for Spring Boot, this
a very popular framework
that people use for
the back-end today.
And this is all it takes.
Like, all of these
lines of code is
all it takes for you to
start a web server that
can handle some requests.
So for example, if
I want to handle
a request that says hello,
the first thing that I do
is to create a class.
That would be something
like Hello World controller,
like that.
And then you can
create a function here,
say hello, fun hello.
And then maybe I'm taking a name
the other request perimeter,
that's a string, and is going to
be equal to hello with a name.
And I can annotate this
with hello RestController.
And then for the function, I
need to listen on a GET method.
So I can use GetMapping and
listen to the hello URI.
And that is all I need to do
to create an endpoint that
response to this /hello.
Now for this
application, though, we
need to do a lot more than
just saying Hello World.
We need CRUD operations.
We need something
that's RESTful.
So, typically,
what people do then
is to go ahead and implement.
And using the controllers,
using these mapping
annotations, you implement
the rest of the API.
So, for example, you need
Post to create a new object.
You need to use GET to
retrieve the list of photos.
Delete and Put for the
updating and deletion.
Right?
And there's a lot
of TODOs you may
have to use to add
to your application.
And these are some
boilerplate code.
Now, in Spring, what
is really, really cool
is that they have
a project called
Spring Data and this
allows you to add object
mappings to your data class.
So in our case, we
have a data class here
called photo that has
all the attributes I
want to store in the database.
And what I can do is to go
to my dependencies here,
and I can actually just
add a dependency here
for our data store.
So you can use object mapping
to SQL databases in the back-end
or in a MongoDB
or in my case, I'm
going to use Cloud Datastore,
which is just a no SQL data
store, a document-oriented
data store that
can use Google Cloud Platform.
And once you have added this
dependency, in the data class,
all you need to do
is to say annotate
it with Entity annotation.
So that will tell
Spring that this data
class can be stored in the
back-end database somewhere.
And for the Id, I'm going to
mark it as the primary key
by using the Id
annotation just like that.
So now that Spring
understands this data class,
the next thing
that we need to do
is to implement some
of the CRUD operations.
Rather than implementing all
of the operations ourselves,
we're just going to
define the interface.
I'm going to call it
PhotoRepository, like that.
And it's going to go ahead
and extend something called
the PagingAndSortingRepository
for the type of photo,
that's the domain type, and
the key type is the string.
And just like that,
the Spring framework
will automatically implement
the CRUD operations for you.
So now I can actually save
date, I can retrieve data.
We're going to go
even a step further.
We're going to put this as
a RESTful resource as well.
And this will also
expose the CRUD operation
as RESTful resources that
I can hit from my endpoint.
I'm going to go ahead and run
it and see this up and running.
So in my [INAUDIBLE] run my
application and Spring Booth
should start up in about
five seconds or so.
There we go.
And this is ready to
handle some requests.
It's listening on port 8080.
And from here on out,
I can just go ahead
and I can make some
requests, right?
And the easy way for me
to do it, I can use curl,
I can use Wget.
But I'm just going
to create a new file.
I'm going to call
this request.http.
And I can just go ahead
and make a GET request.
So I can go ahead and
maybe say hello to myself.
I'm going to say hello,
name is equal to Ray.
And let's run it.
And there we go.
We can see "hello Ray," right?
And we can go and test our
repository in the back-end
as well.
For this one, I'm going to
go ahead and say port 8080.
I'm going to see if I can
find a list of photos.
Now, my laptop's
already authenticated
with Google Cloud.
And so when I'm
doing this operation,
it actually connected
to the data store
and I can clearly see, I have
no photo data entry here.
So we can ahead and just
try to POST something.
So I'm going to say PDR.
Let's POST just an entry here.
So I'm going to say
POST to 8080 to photos.
I'm going to say the id is--
I'm just going to make
something up, 123.
And maybe URI is hello,
something, whatever.
That we can add.
And let's go ahead POST it.
And we can see clearly that
this POST operation also
went through.
And not only that, we
also got a URL back.
And this is the unique
URL that Spring already
implemented for us.
And we can, for example, can
go in and GET it, as well.
And we can see the details.
All of these things are ready
stored in the Datastore data
base.
So for example, I can go ahead
and go to my Google Cloud
console.
I can go to
Datastore right here.
And I can see all of the
entities that have already
created.
In our case, we have photo.
And that is the
entry I just posted.
I can, of course,
delete it, as well.
So I can do that from here,
from the console, if I want to.
And there it goes.
But we need to do
a little bit more
than just CRUD operations
on a RESTful resource.
We need to be able
to upload a file,
because remember we
have to upload a photo.
Now where would you
actually store the photo?
You can actually store that--
typically what people do is
maybe store them on a disk.
On Google Cloud, we have
something called Google Cloud
Storage.
And with Google
Cloud Storage, you
can store your binary blocks,
so whether it's audio, video,
photos, or whatever.
And you don't have to
store that on your disk,
you can just push
it to the service
and you don't have to
worry about the space
that you're going to
be using, because we
will take care of that for you.
And so, in our
browser here, I can
see clearly I have a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
This is a top level directory.
If I go into it, I have
with a demo directory.
And, from here,
this is where I'm
going to put the photo
that we're going to upload.
And, because of this, I'm
going to go ahead and add
a little prefix here
in my controller.
So this is where I'm
going to store my photos.
And I'm going to just create
an upload handler here
for uploading the photo.
In this case, I'm going
to handle a POST method
on /upload.
And I'm going to
go ahead and try
to store the file
that we are going
to get from the parameter.
And the way I'm going to do
it is by-- because we have
integration with the Spring
ecosystem, what we can do
is to just grab what we
call application context.
This is something that
Spring will automatically
inject into your constructor
if you declare it.
And from this context, we can
go ahead and create a resource
where we can say
applicationContext.getResource
and use the prefix and
the id as the file name.
And this reference
now points to the file
that may or may not exist.
And, from here,
from the resource,
we can just go ahead and
write our data into it.
So, from the output stream,
I'm going to USE it.
And I'm going to do the write.
Here we go.
Write.
And write from the
bytes from the file.
And that is all I need to do
to upload a file in my Google
Cloud Storage environment.
And, finally, we're going to
add this piece of metadata
into our Datastore as well.
So I'm going to just
use the photo repository
that I created earlier.
And, again, we can use
dependency injection, just
by adding the photo
repository here.
And we can say
photoRepository.save.
The photo item here.
And the id is equal to the
id [INAUDIBLE] and the URI
that you can use to
retrieve the photo.
I'm going to say image/$id.
And that is how you can
implement a POST method that
handle the upload of a file.
We need to also
retrieve the file.
So for this one, I
already wrote it out.
So basically you have URI
mapping here for image
And you can see the id here
is in part of the path.
And we just use
annotation here to link
and say that this variable is
actually coming from the path.
And similarly, we can
do the deletion as well.
And as you can see,
rather than writing
a lot of the
boilerplate code, we're
just using these integrations
to do the deletions.
And I can delete
the data as well.
So with that, I'm going to
go ahead and deploy this
into a production environment.
Now usually, usually
you want to try this out
in a local environment
first, but we
don't have a lot of time.
So we're going to go
ahead and deploy this
into Google App Engine.
App Engine which is just
a platform as a service
that you can use to run
your production app.
And we can actually run your
Kotlin application and Kotlin
services as well.
The easiest way for
you to deploy this app
is by using our IDE
plugin called Cloud Code.
So from this IDE, you can go
ahead and add the App Engine
support into your project.
So I'm to go ahead
and select it.
And this would just add
the support for the IDE.
And also add a file called
the appengine-web.xml.
I'm going to open
this up a little bit
and show you what
you can do here.
So this is where you configure
the deployment runtime
environment.
So we are using
the runtime here,
where by default,
it's going to give you
a pretty small instance that
you can run a small application.
But for us, we're going to
increase the instance class
size, so we have a
bigger instance size,
so we have more memory
that we can use.
And also by default, it's going
to use automatically scaling.
What that means is that, if no
one's using your application,
it's going to downscale
your app instances to zero,
so you don't have to pay for it.
If somebody makes
a request, we're
going to spin up the instance
for you automatically.
If your application
is very popular,
then we'll spin up even
more instances for you.
For my demo, I'm just
going to go ahead and use
the manual scaling
here, so that I always
know I have two instances
running at any given time.
So this is pretty
much ready to deploy.
But I'm also going to just add
a little filter here of my own
for my application.
So what I'd just added is
just a little filter here
that's going to be looking
for some secret headers
that we're going to pass along
so that our application can
communicate with us.
So it's almost ready to deploy.
And in the IDE, we can
also go ahead and just
get the configuration here.
And we can configure the
Google App Engine deployment.
And I'm just going
to add one-- oh, I
think there's one here already.
So we can pick and choose the
application we want to deploy.
And then we can pick and
choose the Google Cloud project
that we want to deploy to.
And we have a demo project
here that I'm going to select.
And then if I go down
even a little bit more,
we should be able to
see the promotion,
like what version
we want to use.
I'm going to go
ahead and apply it.
I'm going to say, OK.
And now I'm ready to deploy.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run this deployment.
Remember what's going to
happen behind the scenes.
It's going to compile
my Kotlin application.
It's go to create
this WAR package.
It's got to upload
everything into Google Cloud.
And it's also going to give
you a URL that you can actually
use.
And very quickly, we should be
able to see this application up
and running.
Now I'm going to go
back to my console,
just to show you this
service that we have created.
So this is the console where I
have the new service I created.
And I will have a version
that I just created as well.
And as you can see
here, the traffic
is not actually going
through to this new version,
because I was not able to check
the checkbox for promotion.
But now, I know that
this is deploying.
I'm going to go to migrate all
the traffic to this new version
as well.
So now we're going to shift
other traffic from something
that doesn't respond
to any requests
and I'm going to shift
to this new application
I just wrote, that I hope
is going to start and work.
And let's take a quick look.
So I should be able to go
to this new application.
And-- oh, nice.
I think this is working.
So I should be able to
say hello to myself.
There we go.
So I just wrote this and this
is actually up and running.
If I go back to the
Android app, now--
remember, the Android
app is retrofit to talk
to the back-end right now.
And if everything
is working fine,
I should be able to go ahead
and find one of the photos.
And maybe we can upload it.
And remember, it goes
into that /upload handler.
And very quickly
it should return
and we should be able
to see this picture.
Upload complete.
And-- oh, let me see here, just
make sure this is still there.
Yeah, there it is.
And we are able to
upload our photo.
Pretty cool, right?
So--
HADI HARIRI: Yes.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So for the next
part Hadi's going
to show you a little bit about
how to write this in Ktor.
HADI HARIRI: Yes.
And I'll probably try and
talk a little bit slower.
RAY TSANG: OK, yeah.
HADI HARIRI: OK.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
Yeah.
So Ktor is-- how many of
you have heard of Ktor?
Oh, wow.
Cool.
So Ktor is a connected system
application for writing--
it doesn't say it
there, but I'll
say microservices, because
then everybody likes it.
Microservices using blockchain,
now there's no blockchain,
but it'll sound nice as well.
And AI.
There's no AI either,
but it'll be cool.
So this is-- essentially Ktor
is a multiplatform library
framework that
allows you to write
server-side and
client-side applications.
So what I'm going
to show you today
is how you can do
server-side application.
And it's built from the
ground up with Kotlin
using co-routines as well.
Similar to the
start.spring.io, we
have start.ktor.io, which has,
again, similar functionality.
So you can select whether
it's a Gradle or Maven
project, the different
features you want, et cetera.
But I'm going to show you
that you can do this also
in the IDE.
So I can say a new project.
Here I'll select Ktor.
I'll say that I want
some static content.
That's going to ask me
for some information.
I can even add a Swagger
model if I want there.
And go ahead and finish that.
And now I'll select auto import.
And OK.
And now I've got
my Ktor application
imported into IntelliJ.
And essentially, you
can see that it's
created a single file, which
is where my application starts.
So, in this case, and I'll
explain this in a second,
but basically I'm
responding to a Hello World
and I'm responding to
some static resources.
So if we go ahead
and run this, this
will essentially start up Ktor.
And one cool thing
about Ktor, you'll see,
is that the actual start
time is significantly faster
than some other technology,
which I'm not going to mention,
that someone was showing.
So I already have this
Ktor application running.
And you can see that I
have Hello World there.
Now let's switch back to
our actual application.
And let me show you a
little bit how this works.
So first of all, you've got
your application routing.
Now, if you look
at the demo, what
I'm doing here is
essentially, I am
putting all of my
different routes
inside of a table, which is
called the routing table.
Now, this is great for demos,
but it doesn't actually
scale that well if you're
doing a real-world application.
You can't have
everything in one file,
unless you're doing JavaScript.
So, here, what I want to do is--
no disrespect to JavaScript.
What I want to do here is
try and separate things out.
So for instance, I can
do a home function.
And then I can have a
file called home here,
where I actually
write everything
that has to do with my
home, routing, et cetera.
And you don't need
to use functions.
You can actually use classes,
if you want, as well.
That's the flexibility of Ktor.
So whereas with Spring,
you have to map basically
your controller to these routes,
with Ktor you can use functions
or you can just use
classes, however you want.
So I'm going to
write a function.
Now this could be any
function, but since we're
Kotlin, what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to create an
extension function en route.
And what that gives
me access to some
of the features of actual Ktor.
So here I can now do GET.
And then I'll say to
GET the home path.
And I'll do something like
call respond text and hello.
So this is basically going
to respond with hello
from my actual route.
So you can see that
if I run this--
and noticed that
when I'm running it,
I'm using this little
line here, which
is allowing me to run
this locally using
Jetty and remotely using a
different deployment engine.
So that's one of the cool things
with Ktor as well, that you
can actually run something
locally with one engine
and remotely with another.
So you can deploy with Netty,
run locally with Jetty.
And I can pass different
configuration files.
It's using HOCON format
for configurations.
So you can see that I have
my application config, which
is what I ship when
I want to deploy.
But for debug, I
actually indicate
that I want to set a
specific port, et cetera.
So let's go ahead and run this.
And you can see that I've
got my application now
running locally, responding
to the actual endpoint.
So you can see that
it's running here.
And it's not
running, because I've
got another application
running, which
I should be stopping this.
So now it should be able to run.
So now I launch this and I've
got my Hello World there.
Now let's go ahead and
develop some of those things
that we were talking about.
So first thing I want to
do is implement that button
that converts to monochrome.
So look how fast I type.
So there is our monochrome.
Now-- I was way faster
than you, my friend.
RAY TSANG: I know.
Way faster.
HADI HARIRI: Way faster.
So here what I'm doing
is exactly the same thing
as we saw before, but in
this case, it's a PUT.
So I'm loading the image
with call parameters.
And then I'm doing
call.loadFromStorage.
Now call is part of Ktor, but
loadFromStorage is actually
a Google Cloud Function.
But again, we're
dealing with Kotlin,
so I can implement an extension
function that actually
talks to Cloud Storage.
And integrate that as part
of my application call,
which is the response
request that Ktor deals with.
So I load this from storage.
This is going to give
me back a result.
I'm a good boy here, because
I'm basically analyzing
a success and a failure.
I'm going to then convert
it to monochrome, which
is a really, really bad
implementation of converting
to monochrome.
And then I'm going
to save to storage.
If everything is
OK, I'll hit OK.
If something goes
wrong, what do we do,
we always throw internal
server error 500.
It doesn't matter what it is.
Just a 500 is absolutely OK.
And then you can actually
point to the real message
with a text.
That is a joke, by the
way, I'm being sarcastic.
So internal server error and
now I go ahead and run this.
Now this is nice.
I could actually deploy this
and it probably will might work.
Might, yeah.
But the problem is
that here, notice
that I've got this like mono/id
and then I've got this id
and this is essentially text.
And if I want to rename this,
if I want to rename this route,
this is kind of
like problematic.
Because I've got to look
for search for text--
I mean, if you're
using IntelliJ,
it'll probably fix it for you.
But let's try and do
this in a better way.
And what we can do is implement
this location functionality
that comes with Ktor.
Which basically I can say
to search for location
and I'm going to
create a class called
mono that has a single
parameter, which is id.
And then what I'm
going to do is instead
of using this format
of PUT, I'm going
to use a generic type
of PUT, which is mono.
So that's going to import
the correct mono, which
is location.
And then instead of using
core parameters, what I can do
is actually, this
is a lambda, so I
can pass the strongly typed
parameter to my function.
Which is all of the parameters
that are part of the route.
So here-- I actually need to
define the route properly,
so it would be id.
So here I would do
id and then instead
of doing this call
parameters like that,
I can just access it via id.
Now in this case, it would be--
Sorry.
This would be mono.id and
this would be mono.id.
Mono-- and then mono dot.id.
Now if you're
familiar with Kotlin,
you know that if a lambda
takes a single parameter,
I don't have to be
explicit with it,
so I could actually remove this
and just refer to this as it.
So this gives me it.id.
And now I have access to my tie
to my route in a strong way.
So I have access
to the parameters.
I don't need to
do any conversions
or anything like that.
And this will actually work.
If I deploy this,
this will work.
But the problem here is
that this is kind of slow.
I know, because
I implemented it.
And if this is
running very long,
Ktor will try and prevent your
thread requests from blocking.
However, it is recommended
that you offload this
to another co-routine.
So essentially,
what I would do here
is go ahead and
write withContext
and then Dispatchers.IO--
it has nothing
to do with this conference.
OK, that was not funny?
No?
OK.
So now what I'm doing
is I'm putting this
into the Dispatchers.IO, which
is really cool, because now
it's going off into
another thread.
It's not blocking any
potential requests coming in.
And I don't have to worry about
safely putting things back,
because with co-routines,
I can just dump and access
whatever I want, where I want.
And this will now convert
an image to monochrome.
Now before we deploy, let me
show you some other things
that you can do with Ktor.
So here is a t-share.
So what this is-- not
a t-share, a share.
And what this is
doing is essentially
allowing me to share an image.
So when I click on
the Share button,
it's going to give me a URL
that I can then paste and send
to someone and it will share it.
And what I'm going
to show you here
is how Ktor can actually
send back HTML as well.
Now, of course, I could
do something like HTML
like this in String,
but that isn't cool.
What we can do is combine
this with Kotlin XHTML.
So I could in fact write
body and then here write,
for example, H1.
And then write the lambda.
And then say, for example
"Hello look at this image."
and then let's do a br.
And then let's do, for
example, the actual image
that is showing the image.
So I'm integrating very nicely
that Kotlin XHTML library
with Ktor.
Works very nicely.
And you can just
basically send back HTML.
Now before we deploy
this, one thing
that we've got to be aware
of is we need to add this
to our routing table.
So if I go back to Main, I
have to come here and write
convertToMonochrome.
And I have to also do the share.
So I've now added
this to my table.
And then I should be able to
just deploy to App Engine.
Here I'm going to say promote
this to the next version.
Select-- really?
Seriously?
RAY TSANG: You have
to login first.
HADI HARIRI: [SINGING]
(SPOKEN) Can we sing that?
No?
We can't allow--
[HUMMING]
Yes.
Go ahead.
[HUMMING]
There you go.
I can't complain that
this isn't my machine,
because it is my machine.
So I've deployed this.
And now it is
successfully deployed.
It's uploaded.
It's already started.
And you're still deploying
your Spring, right?
RAY TSANG: No, mine
was already working.
HADI HARIRI: Oh,
but has it started?
RAY TSANG: Oh.
It's always starting.
HADI HARIRI: It's
always starting.
RAY TSANG: I have
manual scaling.
Yeah.
HADI HARIRI: Manual scaling.
So this is done sending
traffic split for service.
So now I can basically
access my endpoint,
but instead of
accessing it like that,
let me go to my Android
application that Seth wrote.
And remember, if anything goes
wrong here, it's his fault.
So we've got our images here.
And I can click on
my image over here.
And this is the moment of truth.
Convert to monochrome.
Come on, come on,
come on, come on.
RAY TSANG: Come on.
So this first request
might be a little slow,
because you have
automatic scaling, right?
So we're actually starting
a brand new instance for you
behind the scenes.
HADI HARIRI: I also put error
while hipsterring image.
RAY TSANG: Hips--
what does that mean?
HADI HARIRI: What
does that mean?
I think hipsters make
their images monochrome.
RAY TSANG: Oh, I see.
HADI HARIRI: I've been
waiting for so long.
RAY TSANG: That's pretty good.
HADI HARIRI: So OK, so we can
actually switch over to the--
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
What happened?
HADI HARIRI: Yes.
Switch over to-- can we
switch over to Ray's machine?
RAY TSANG: Yep.
HADI HARIRI: OK.
So tell me what's
gone wrong, man.
RAY TSANG: Well, let's see
what will we actually deploy.
So what is pretty cool
here is that you can see,
we actually deploy two
different services.
So his application did not
overwrite my service, right?
So we can specify the different
names for the applications,
so they don't
overwrite each other.
So default is the one I deployed
that's using String Boot.
And the ktor one
is the one that he
deployed using Ktor, of course.
If I go in here, I can
see the different versions
that we have and
this is the latest
version that he deployed.
And that's the previous version
that should ideally work.
HADI HARIRI: That
should ideally work.
RAY TSANG: So we can
fix this, for example,
by simply shifting the
traffic and migrate it
to the version that works.
And I would take care of it.
But I'm kind of
interested to see what
is going on behind the scenes.
So for that matter, we can
go into the diagnosis tools.
And I could go in and see--
we can do a few things.
We can debug the code live
or we can see the log.
I'm going to show
you log for now.
So let me see if I can
get any log messages.
Oh check it out.
So we actually do have
a PUT here with a 200,
so it actually kind
of went through.
And then we have mono.
And we can see some
log messages here.
It looks like it might be OK.
So let me see here.
I'm going to go ahead
and do a refresh.
Oh actually, you know what?
It did actually go.
HADI HARIRI: There you go.
You see it was Seth's fault.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
Something on the front-end.
HADI HARIRI: Yeah.
But we--
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
So we actually planned
that, so that we show you
that error logs, really, right?
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
HADI HARIRI: Yeah.
OK.
Yes.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, sure.
HADI HARIRI: So there you go.
So we're going to switch back
over to my machine, please.
RAY TSANG: Yep, back to--
HADI HARIRI: That's me, Hadi.
Yes, there you go.
So they don't know who my is.
So the last thing
that we're going to do
is opening up this
application again.
Where's my application?
We also have the share, so
basically this copies it over
to my browser.
And I can come here and I can
paste that into my browser.
And you say, hello
look at this image.
So you've got to share
with the HTML man as well.
It's OK, you can clap.
It's OK.
I know that you want to clap.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
So we've got that.
Now it's over to you.
RAY TSANG: Yeah.
So wait a second, though,
let's switch back to my machine
again.
I'm going to show this
application very quickly.
Now Hadi, check this out.
When I opened up this picture,
which I took, check it out.
There's a little
label underneath here
that says wood, because
that's the material, I guess,
that was used to
make this thing.
If I click into this other
picture, it's got insects.
Right?
HADI HARIRI: Don't tell me.
Don't tell me that you're going
to add artificial intelligence
to this talk.
RAY TSANG: It's already there.
HADI HARIRI: Oh my god.
This is so cool.
RAY TSANG: It's
already there, right?
So I can't actually-- this one--
HADI HARIRI: You can't have
a talk without AI, right?
You have to have ML and AI.
RAY TSANG: That's right.
So I'm going to upload one
of my favorite picture.
It's a really cute dog.
It's not my dog, by the way.
I wish it is.
But if I--
HADI HARIRI: It's an ugly dog.
RAY TSANG: --in there,
it's actually a pug.
So where did that
actually come from?
You saw me write the code.
I can guarantee you that
everything I just wrote
was live.
That application did not write
the label into this artifact.
So what happened
behind the scenes
is I actually deployed
this other thing, way
before the dog, and
it's called a function.
In Google Cloud, we
have cloud function,
so you can actually write a
very small snippet of code
and it can respond to events.
The event can be
coming from HTTP
or it can be coming from things
like Google Cloud Storage,
so that when you upload a
picture, or any of the files,
we can trigger this
function as well.
If you are using Firestore or
some other things that we have,
you can also receive
notifications
when you make changes.
So I'm going to go ahead
and go back to my IDE.
And I actually opened up
the function right here.
So this is a function
that's written with Kotlin.
And function can run
this code is fine.
And one thing you have to
watch out for is that you do
need to actually create a class.
And then you wrap the actual
function inside of the class.
That's because we actually
need to instantiate
the class for you, so
that we can initialize
some of the client libraries
that you may actually
have to use.
And this function is
going to take in an event.
For example, if it's
HTTP, we're going
to have some kind of HTTP
request and response.
In our case, we're going to
respond to a Google Cloud
Storage event, which is a
well-defined schema that you
can read the documentation for.
But you actually definitely
have these two fields in there.
It's really a JSON format.
And we're going to serialize
it for you into your data class
as well.
So in this function, we
have applyVisionLabel,
that's going to
receive the event that
has the bucket and also the
file name that's been changed.
And we basically just
use a Cloud Vision API
to read this file and see
what's actually inside.
And so here we
are actually doing
a feature, a label detection.
We're going to only get
the maximum of 3 results.
And then, for the labels,
we're going to just iterate
through the actual result list.
We're going to sort by
descending by the score.
And then we're going to
map it to the description.
And finally, we're
going to add it
as a delimited list,
just a string that's
been delimited by a comma.
And this is all happening behind
the scenes asynchronously.
And the way that you
would deploy this function
is pretty straightforward.
Actually, if I go to here--
Actually, you know what, I'm
going to open the Read Me here,
so it's a little
bit easier to read.
So if I want to
deploy the function,
I can just say gcloud
function, glcoud [INAUDIBLE]
gcloud function deploy.
And then give it the
name of the project.
And also the entry point,
which is the class name.
And also the metonym.
And then you can specify
the event trigger
that you want to listen to.
So, for our case, we're
listening to the Google Cloud
Storage object event trigger.
And that is how we then
run the Vision API.
And then we update the label.
And, of course, if I
go to my console here--
Let me go back to my IDE.
Or actually, you know what?
I'm going to go here.
And, if I go back to my
application, my App Engine
application, if I go
back to the service
that I have just deployed
in default. There you go.
Let me open this up.
And let me just open up
the photo's endpoint.
Because that you remember, this
is where a Sprint implemented
all the CRUD access for me.
And I can see very clearly, even
though I just wrote the URI,
my function has rewrote
the label for me.
HADI HARIRI: That
is one ugly JSON.
RAY TSANG: What do you mean?
HADI HARIRI: It's ugly.
It's got, like, underline and--
RAY TSANG: What?
HADI HARIRI: I've got
much better JSON for you.
RAY TSANG: Really?
HADI HARIRI: Open up my app.
RAY TSANG: Yeah, where's your-
HADI HARIRI: And notice that
we've got two different apps.
We've got the Spring
and we've got the Ktor.
RAY TSANG: What do you mean?
HADI HARIRI: Go to my app.
And put--
RAY TSANG: OK, I see hello.
HADI HARIRI: Yeah,
no, it's got more.
OK, /data, /all.
Now that's some
nice looking JSON.
RAY TSANG: Is it?
HADI HARIRI: Oh.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
RAY TSANG: Hadi, I think
you have a way of crashing
the system with JSONs.
I'm telling you--
HADI HARIRI: Oh, you're going
to bring up the JSON thing now,
right?
RAY TSANG: Did it not work
today in the morning, either.
HADI HARIRI: Thank you.
So what's going on there?
Open up the panel.
RAY TSANG: Another
400 error here.
Let's take a quick look.
So we kind of already saw,
you can go in and see the log.
Let me show you
something else here.
So we can-- there are
other request that's
coming through App Engine.
It's automatically
going through the trace.
So we can actually go here
and see the list of requests.
So every dot here is a
request that's going through.
And we can filter it by the
request based on the HTTP
status, for example.
So we can see--
ah-ha, look, there's
your request.
HADI HARIRI: OK, fine.
RAY TSANG: It actually failed.
And if I scroll
down a little bit,
we can also see the log as well.
So if there is correlation,
when we open up this View Log,
we should be able to see the
log message that's associated
with this particular request.
And look, it actually found this
entry, which is pretty cool.
And we can see the 500 error.
And if I scroll down
even a little bit more--
aw, Hadi, you have
an exception here.
HADI HARIRI: Oh.
OK, so--
RAY TSANG: What is this?
HADI HARIRI: --I
know what that means.
So let's switch
over to my screen
and I'll tell you what
the problem there is.
RAY TSANG: You're
going to fix up?
HADI HARIRI: Yeah, I'm--
RAY TSANG: All right.
All right, all right.
HADI HARIRI: Right.
So this is the actual
endpoint that he called.
And what we see here, there's
another feature of Ktor
that we're using, which
is nested routing.
So here, before, where
we were saying just
like a GET in the
path, you can actually
have even nested routes in Ktor.
So I define a route,
and then /all.
And, in this case, all I'm
doing is querying the data store
and then saying call.respond.
Now, this is automatically
serializing this to JSON.
The problem is,
as the log shows,
is that I forgot to tell Ktor
that I want the JSONs content
negotiation feature.
And the way that you
do that, is that you
come to your
application, and you
say install(ContentNegotiation)
and then
the content negotiation has
support for different types
of serializers.
So I could say,
for instance, GSON.
And then GSON has its
own set of parameters,
so I could say pretty
printer, setPrettyPrinting.
And because this is GSON, it
knows exactly what GSON has.
So we have support for GSON
and Jackson, et cetera.
And that's what the problem was.
I was not telling Ktor how to
do the actual serialization.
And now, basically, if
we deploy this again,
and I'm going to stop that,
because we need to promote it.
So we're going to deploy.
And it's killing me.
So you can promote
that directly.
RAY TSANG: OK, yeah, sure.
HADI HARIRI: But, anyway,
that should be promoted now.
And I didn't promote it
at the latest version,
he's going to now do
it from the console.
So while he's doing
that, I can switch over.
And, in principle, this is
still giving the 500 error
until he promotes the new
version from the console.
And then I'll have the
new version showing here
and we should be good.
Promoted?
RAY TSANG: Not yet.
I think your deployment
operation is still not
quite finished.
HADI HARIRI: Ah, yes.
It's still deploying.
RAY TSANG: Are you
connected to the internet?
OK, yeah, you are.
HADI HARIRI: Yes.
RAY TSANG: OK.
So basically because he
was doing the deployment,
we cannot do a simultaneous
operation here from
the console.
So now it should be migrating.
So I just, on my
machine, I'm trying
to migrate the traffic over.
You probably saw that earlier.
In addition to
migrating traffic,
we can also split traffic
between two different versions
of the app.
And now it's migrated over.
HADI HARIRI: OK so--
RAY TSANG: Hopefully.
HADI HARIRI: You see
that I didn't promote
and we did it from the console.
So now, switching over
here, we should be
able to see my JSON come back.
And it doesn't matter even
if it doesn't, because we're
running out of time.
So even if it gives a 500
error, everything is OK,
and all my JSON failed today.
RAY TSANG: That's a record.
HADI HARIRI: That's two JSONs--
BOTH: Oh, there you go.
HADI HARIRI: Beautiful, right?
RAY TSANG: Great job.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
HADI HARIRI: So
that's basically it.
Switch back to the slides--
RAY TSANG: Let's switch
back to my screen,
please, so that we can close up.
So we saw a lot.
I mean, we went
relatively quick.
But we do have quite
a few resources
you should probably go visit.
So for example--
And obviously, the Kotlin pages.
But also you can go to
cloud.google.com/Kotlin.
This is where you can
learn a lot more about how
you can actually write your
Kotlin application and deploy
into Google App Engine.
And we have some community
tutorials and collabs
you can follow.
If you want to do even deeper
integration, with Spring,
for example, we have a whole
range of resources there.
And finally, if you want to
try Google Cloud Function,
you can sign up for that.
You do have to sign up, because
it's in alpha right now.
And for Google App Engine,
we do have a new version
that's coming out.
Where you can also get
the alpha signed up today,
so that you can try and deploy a
JAR file instead of a WAR file.
So that is all we have today.
And yeah, thank you all--
HADI HARIRI: Thank
you for coming.
RAY TSANG: --for being here.
Thank you.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]